uh this is also a good place to give a  shout out to a video titled the entire  soviet rocket engine family tree by tim  dodd aka everyday astronaut it's like an  hour and a half it gives a full history  of soviet rockets  and people should definitely go check on  support tim in general that guy is super  excited about the future super excited  about space flight every time i see  anything by him i just have a stupid  smile on my face because he's so excited  about stuff  yeah i love people like  great if you're interested in anything  to do with space um he's in terms of uh  explaining  rocket technology to your average person  he's awesome the best i'd say  you